[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 73
our last one was on the uh
the equinox it was it was on the equinox
yes
yes yes it was that one ran it through
my head too equinox or solstice no
on the equinox we are now solidly into
spring
which i am pleased to say will allow us
to revive a dark horse tradition
which means we can now start warning
people that winter is coming
that's an honorable and
to abandon when winter arrived i should
say if you are one of our southern
hemisphere viewers you may want to
hit pause and return to this episode six
months from now so it all makes sense
yes yes i would say do that indeed so
today we're going to talk about
diversity of things
including the fact that it is our
basically our one year anniversary
here for the evolutionary lens which is
these live streams that we do together
we're going to spend a little time
talking about that at the top of the
hour
uh and we're going to talk about
the politics behind the origins of
sarsko v2
and a little bit about the politics of
detransitioning
and about um what we can blame the
amazon rainforest for
oh yeah oh yeah that rainforest about
time
yep and let's see oh and um
whether or not saffron can bring you
happiness yep
yep i feel like i've missed something
there but uh that seems like a
a good set of things but first just
announcements um
we do a once a month private q a
for people who join us at my patreon
and it is always the last sunday of the
month at 11 a.m pacific for two hours
uh that is tomorrow so um the questions
have already been
been posed for this month but it's a
it's a it's it's a lot of fun for us
it's small enough community that we can
actually watch and engage the chat
as it happens and we leave those up for
patrons afterwards
um so i think we're on our i don't
remember our 9th or 10th at this point
8th or 9th maybe um and that'll be
tomorrow so it's going to be awesome
it's always fun
it is we get to keep an eye on the chat
and interact with people it's it's
different than uh what goes on here yeah
good as this is indeed
okay so it is uh march 24th three days
ago was our one year anniversary the
the one year anniversary of us beginning
these live streams
uh we did a 72 episodes
and we've been grateful for and honored
by your responses or you know most of
them
the vast majority of them have been a
few that we weren't grateful for or
honored by but
you know that's youtube i mean frankly
that's spectacular only to have a small
number of such reactions absolutely
um and you know including all the other
sort of immediate response but um
why don't you start us off uh by just
telling how did we get here
tell how did we get there also why now
oh no you know things have gotten rough
at the point we get to why now but yeah
yeah so uh just for those of you who
have started paying attention to
darkhorse since the beginning of our
live streams and may not realize how we
ended up here and
want to know something about the
relationship of the live streams to the
other stuff that goes on
what happened was we started or i should
say i started the darkhorse podcast
as the the idea was it was part of a
long-term
project and i wanted to highlight dark
horses these are people who
[Music]
are difficult to predict in terms of
their capacity because they've
grown up in some unusual way and they do
interesting things
that was the original intent was to talk
to those people and
at the point that uh kova descended on
the world
and forced us to change everything we
found ourselves
in two predicaments one we couldn't keep
going to the place where the dark course
podcast
studio was set up the office space that
we had in downtown portland
and so we had to move here and zach and
i
built this set here in
basically an afternoon or an afternoon a
weekend of
trips back and forth to the hardware
store and uh nailing things to the wall
and all that
didn't our younger son toby also help
with some of the attic work and uh
oh yes well toby was instrumental in the
wiring
of the set which is actually uh
surprisingly
uh complex but in any case we built up
the uh
the set and then tried to figure out
what to do
the ability to interview people in the
studio was going to go crashing to zero
and uh you and i were
thrust into this discussion in a way as
biologists
watching a pandemic unfold a pandemic
that have has obvious evolutionary
dimensions there was a lot to be said
and we were getting this flood of
information coming in on
what was being discovered about the
virus itself about its epidemiology
uh its history and all of that and so we
started doing
live streams you and me so for those of
you who are wondering why this is brett
weinstein's star course podcast and yet
most of the time when you tune in and in
fact all of the times that you tune into
the live
program it's obviously symmetrically you
and me so why is my name on
the door well early on before we had any
idea how long we would be doing live
streams or what they would be
um about you know at first it was all
coveted or almost
all we had a discussion about this was
significantly different from what had
been going on on dark horse
previously and should we put it on a
different channel and
come up with a different title or was it
temporary and
should we leave things as they were and
anyway we ended up
deciding to stick with the name that we
had and the graphics that we had and
just added in the live streams which for
those of you who are wondering why that
has happened that is the answer and i
would say
i have some regret over it because
obviously the live streams are distinct
from the other things and
you know it would make sense for it not
to be
labeled that way on the other hand uh i
would say
a rose by any other name is still rice
i knew you were going to say that did
you i did
you know me that well you know our
spanish-speaking audience is currently
laughing out loud
yes yes yes yes um and you know we have
informally sort of
branded what we're doing as the
evolutionary lens like this is the
evolutionary lens
with with brett and heather um a sort of
a subspecies of the dark horse podcast
and
um you know you have um re-upped the
frequency
again of the one-on-one conversations
that you have which is
the more exactly as you just said what
you would originally
expected to be doing and frankly i mean
the last four alone i mean i haven't
heard one
um yet that you've done that i felt like
and they kind of fell flat but
if memory serves the last four in order
uh were daniel schmottenberger
tristan harris jordan peterson and
irshad manji
and you've got another one ready to
deploy in another conversation
also next week but those four alone are
just extraordinary
and um across such a wide array of
topics and
um you know although you have not i
think until
now really conveyed publicly what what
you had in mind with dark horse i think
all four of those people
are are may i use toby's pluralization
or dark keys
um in in their own ways and that um you
know to to their credit and
um you know i highly recommend all those
conversations as well
great yeah i think the they all um were
really
fascinating and i'm i'm enjoying doing
those conversations
um i'm glad they have sort of uh
found a a rhythm that works and i'm
looking forward to doing more
i will say it has become easier as
everybody
is getting effectively a master's degree
in zoom
it is becoming now quite possible to do
uh these things remotely whereas at the
beginning of covid
it was pretty hit and miss as to whether
or not the tech would work
when we tried to have them so anyway yes
i hope the frequency will keep up and
the quality of them i'm very happy with
it and i hope that keeps going too
but okay here we are a year in and
we have now both the original dark horse
stuff
uh up and running at a relatively high
rate and we have the live streams
uh which have been going on for for a
full year now
um and uh i don't know where does that
take us well i wanted to
um we're not gonna um we are not going
to pretend to do a retrospective
but one one version of some of the
diversity of
places that we've gone in this last year
can be conveyed by just
mentioning just the books that um
i or you have read excerpts from
you know this does not include any of
the essays
or the journal articles the you know
peer reviewed scientific literature that
we have
read from and analyzed of which we've
done a tremendous amount
but just just just the books and it
provides i think an interesting
cross-section of some of where we've
been so
i just put them in an order um that
groups them somewhat and i'll post this
either on the show notes or
you know probably the show notes i guess
if there's if there's room
um and definitely um
definitely on the patreon actually um
okay so
fitting in with no other category i read
a bit from turin and sanchez's perfumes
the guide
and then a number of pieces of fiction
including boccaccio's de cameron
dostoevsky's crime and punishment
heller's catch-22
kundera's the book of laughter and
forgetting orwell's 1984
amato's donaflora and her two husbands
dickens a christmas carol seuss's the
zaks
heinlein's a stranger in a strange land
and abbott's flatland
so that's that's a diverse bit of
fiction there
um then one of my favorite books of all
time now we're into non-fiction
uh sarah blaffer hurdy's mother nature a
truly extraordinary deep dive into
um into the evolutionary nature of
of motherhood and females in general um
john taylor gatto's weapons of mass
instruction
declutter is the cultural revolution of
people's history from 1962-1976
nothing to envy ordinary lives in north
korea
rodriguez uh lived not by lies
a an excellent book based the title was
taken from solchenitzen's essay of the
same name
live not by lies eric hoffer's the true
believer
we spent a fair bit of time
deconstructing d'angelo's white
fragility
and somewhat less time with candies how
to be an anti-racist uh
in keeping with with that but from a
rather different perspective
pluck rose and lindsay's cynical
theories and lucky enough and heights
coddling of the american mind
and the last three michael crawford's
the world beyond your head
sebastian younger's tribe and tiknot
hans 2012 book fear
essential wisdom for getting through the
storm
so that takes us a lot of places yeah
that's a
that's a very eclectic list
but as i'm thinking you know you're
bringing me back to all of the episodes
in which those things
arose and uh that is
um it's a cohesive list too it tells you
something about
the style of thinking that we have been
um
i don't know i don't want to say
deploying because you know in part this
is sort of a
campfire phenomenon itself and um
and so anyway we're building uh this
perspective right here
uh together and and with the audience in
any way i think
it's a great list of things and even if
uh the only
packet of information that made it to
people was hey here's a list of things
that are worth engaging
you know you you could construct pretty
good um foundation for a world view out
of those
those texts absolutely would i regret
now using
immediately text yes it's it's been
abused
it's uh academically abused
indeed okay well that's um that's
maybe all we have to say about the fact
of this being our one year anniversary
episode
uh and then you wanted to segue into
talking about the suez canal i think
uh yeah i mean not the suez canal itself
so much i mean although there are things
to be said about it but i i i will say
um i don't know about you
i am getting a tremendous amount of
correspondence uh from
people that we know who would like us to
comment on the fact that there is
a large vessel with the
giant letters saying the word evergreen
stuck in the suez canal blocking world
trade
blocking blocking progress blocking
progress
and uh somehow a great many people who
follow us and know us um are eager to
hear
our take on this which uh i think you
and i have
spent a lot of the last three days
avoiding deploying a take
on this ship and its um
uh progress to a point uh that it has
made so anyway i think it is now time
that we
that we comment on it okay you you you
do you man
i'm gonna i'm gonna do my best i will
say the people who have been contacting
us i'm beginning to suspect that they
suffer from pdsd post-dramatic situation
disorder
in which they would like to see um
disasters and spectacular catastrophes
analogize together
ad nauseum and uh what would make for
perhaps a more parsimonious world
oh yeah yeah at least it's like we got
okay it's in that category
it's in that yes big things called
evergreen that have
failed in an amazing way yeah okay so
anyway there
there are obviously some similarities
between what has happened in the suez
canal
and what took place at uh at evergreen
state college and some differences
you know here we have a
ship that has become wedged in a canal
whereas at the college
the institution kept getting stuck under
bridges that's
you know similar but not exactly the
same
i will say that if the events are in
fact
really alike then we can make some
predictions about what's coming next
we should expect to see students issue a
long list of demands
then we should expect to see them flee
the ship never to return and we should
expect to see the state of washington
infuse the ship with a large amount of
cash to keep it afloat
the state of washington even well yeah i
mean that's if history
if history repeats itself in this case
that's that's what you would expect
while doing nothing with the state of
washington will infuse it with resources
while doing nothing to correct its path
and allow it to freeze they will double
down
on its current path they will i don't
know i don't know exactly how you do
that in this case but yes something
something along those lines
but i will say that the whole event um
really can be viewed in a couple of
different ways
right there's the classical view in
which this is very bad for the world to
have this
ship i mean it seems strange that one
ship can
create such a tangle but when you
realize why the suez canal was put there
and what journey it avoids you know
around the
southern tip of africa in order to get
from
you know asia to europe for example uh
wow one ship really
creates a huge amount of uh trouble and
so you know
from that classical view i would say you
know this is
what happens at a canal when there's no
entrance exam
right i mean one ship can
just block down it's ugly man that's
that bad i think so
okay how would you rate that joke would
i rate it yeah
what's my scale three to 17. 3 to 17
which one is high
17 17 yeah that's a perfectly
straightforward scale yeah i'm i'm
giving that a 5.
all right sort of better than i thought
it was but
yeah i'll take five sure um okay so also
very very in keeping with the current uh
theme of so
how do we analogize things to evergreen
to invent a scale that will be
meaningless outside of the context in
which we are currently discussing things
uninterpretable
uninterpreted yeah no that's uh yeah i'm
very much of the moment that's
what people say about me um no they
really don't
um but okay so that's the classical view
is that this is very bad
but it's not the only way to look at
this there's also a much more modern
sort of a silicon valley dnc
mainstream media view in which this
isn't maybe so terrible
um you know the new york times points
out that this ship had it coming given
the historical connection between
shipping and slavery um yeah it's a
really
it's a it's it's a classic new york
times point
um yeah the aclu
pointed out that this ship has as much
right to block the canal as other ships
have
to transit the canal which i also
thought was pretty insightful
you're giving me well i'm just wondering
if
we're going to get called out for libel
no it's satire it's okay okay
for those of you who are not good with
satire this is satire
which is why it is not liable so this is
you said this is the traditional take is
it's bad so this is like this is the
anti-bad take
you're right this is the maybe it's not
so bad it's anti-bad oh it's anti-bad
it's amazing yeah yeah
you are okay you are intuiting my
direction here okay okay well not
surprisingly we've been married a long
time so you know
intuit away but um all right so planned
parenthood points out that there's
no wrong way to be a ship
which i wonder about it i wonder if they
have anyone on staff who knows
anything at all about ships i i know the
answer to that do you
no no they do not know yeah um
and ebermex candy has argued that this
is a
triumph of critical maritime theory over
traditional colonial meritocratic
navigation
true dat yes yeah absolutely yes
and um if we extend his rubric he didn't
say this of course but
you know the day-to-day transit of the
canal is clearly racist and therefore
this incident can only be
you can fill in the blank at home yeah
all right um
and you know i will say okay so that's
the the more modern
take but even i am forced to admit that
this transit was mostly peaceful
indeed yeah yeah yeah that's not bad
although yes you know as as
the clock continues to tick and it
continues to be jammed up
doesn't it become less and less peaceful
as it goes on
uh if we if we take actually higher i
would say that the canal
is more peaceful than it has perhaps
been
since when was it built 18 so this is a
very very clever sleight of hand exactly
in keeping with the
kinds of uh satirical quotations you are
you are now employing uh you were
talking about the ship being most
the transit being mostly peaceful and
you have you have
swapped the argument as i suggested that
the transit actually has become more and
more bogged down the longer it sits
there and you've said well the cow
though
the canal has in fact become more
peaceful the longer
the ship sits there need i point out
that you are deploying
now discredited styles of logic in which
one statement
follows from the prior statement you see
what i'm saying
i i do and i am not going to apologize
you're
yes ultimately you will but uh
we apologize here we apologize when we
are wrong and when we have wronged
someone but we do not apologize
for imagined fictions over in unicorn
space
right unicorn space you've now confused
every vc who watches us
yeah all right so all right that's the
situation we've got the two views of
what has happened
and there's a question about what might
be done about it okay there is
and we're gonna start i have an idea for
what to do
about the of course you do well of
course i do i'm a solution guy i know
you are yeah all right so
my my suggestion is that we get a ship
full of cabbage and
dried
[Laughter]
sounds good so far
cabbage and dried let's see let me guess
it's going to be
um yeah i know i was just trying to come
up with another word that began with fr
but i you know fruit cake no it's just
fruit cabbage and dried fruit
fruit cake would work too but cabbage
and dried fruit solutions
i see in large font on your computer
garbage and dried fruit that's all i see
though so you're gonna have to fill it
in for me that's all you need
you're not helping all right
um and so i admit that i actually don't
know how to help here
it should be obvious how that would help
cabbage and dried fruit yes
the canal is blocked
cabbage cabbage really okay okay
all right so
okay i'm with you you're with me though
this is a nightmare that's good
so um yeah i don't know you you've got
more to go
yeah i do yeah i can't free you here i
can't that
solution of mine right actually does
suggest that this this could possibly be
now you've got the gills yep
i was just going to point out that at
evergreen the failures there arguably
were also the result
of a lack of moral fiber see
connection all right good now let's move
on to uh people who have maybe more
technical expertise and would be better
positioned therefore to suggest
uh a more useful solution to this
problem
elon musk has proposed tunneling under
the ship
jeez i thought i thought you were going
to laugh at that you're just trying to
resist the giggles aren't you because i
think that was pretty good
i no i'm no
maybe i don't get it like i i get go on
all right elon has a plan to solve
traffic in la for example putting
tunnels
under the blocked streets anyway yeah i
thought it wasn't pretty ed
he famously had a plan with the miners
in uh no not the miners the uh children
baseball soccer team yeah yeah yeah i
mean his plan was actually pretty good
was it yeah was it he made a little
submarine
it was not the one that ended up it
wasn't necessary they got them out the
divers got them out amazingly without
harming anybody that's okay i remember
that differently i thought i thought his
plan was uh
discredited and mocked oh he was mocked
i'm not sure why exactly okay
okay i'm glad he was on the case but
okay um all right so
we got elon musk solution tunnel under
um and then
if all else fails we could treat this
disaster like covid
do nothing useful and eventually global
warming will float the ship
up and dislodge it to allow us to get it
through the canal
a rising virus floats all ships
something
yeah yeah something in that neighborhood
all right well we have avoided
having to shut down this episode of dark
horse
live stream over the giggles which i
fear will one day happen
um but in this case we almost had it
happen but
we're still here so i i don't want to be
the
straight man here but you were also
going to say something about part of why
we're avoiding
even engaging this at all is that you
spent you spent a long time in the
panama canal you spent like 19 months
in the panama literally in the past
and i was with you there for four or
five of those months so
um and i had a paramount license the
panama
go for it so i had a panama canal
license which does not mean that i was
licensed
to navigate large ships through the
canal in fact nobody is in the panama
canal
the ships are turned over to uh
i remember what they're called canal
pilots i think so
there's an elite canal pilots
association you have to have
a great deal of expertise and actually
it does tell us something if we're now
in serious mode
well hold on a second i actually didn't
know this so the panama the suez canal
of which i know almost nothing
is just just a narrow canal um
whereas the panama canal is um
two series of locks uh then with
basically what used to be
um terra firma this was the islamist of
panama
that has been flooded and so now the
island on which you spent time by a
colorado island for instance it used to
be a dry hilltop
and so you've got lake cartoon in the
middle of these two locks
and you've also got the situation of the
atlantic the pacific are actually at
different levels
sea level is a different level for the
atlantic the pacific between the two
ends of the panama canal
so unlike the suez the panama canal you
have to go through locks and then you
have to navigate this lake and then you
have to go through locks again yeah so
the panama canal is freshwater the suez
canal will be saltwater and tidal
suez canal has no locks
the panama canal has two sections you've
alluded to lake gatun which is a giant
artificial lake that was made by
flooding this valley that the chagris
river used to
flow through but it has another section
the kulebrakat kulebra meaning snake
the snake cut looks like what everybody
imagines the panama canal will look like
except it's not concrete lined it's
a dirt trench but it's very narrow and
in any case through the entire transit
these ships you know we
uh folks who drive cars and ride bikes
don't intuit how hard it is to navigate
these things these are
vessels designed for the open ocean and
navigating them in tight
quarters is not at all easy because they
have so much momentum
um and so they have to be effectively
pivoted with
uh with tugboats and the captains have
to know exactly
you know basically their full-time job
is captain of large ships in the panama
canal
so that they learn how to do it properly
in any way
it's an amazing operation when you
actually see it i can only assume that
the suez canal has the same issue of
navigation
it is i think a straight line at least
um so apparently it also has a group of
pilots trying to do it
that does not surprise me at all because
of course one schmoe
who you know drinks too much and runs
the thing aground
obviously can grind a huge fraction of
the world's
uh you know freight to a halt
which has potentially huge impacts on
things like prices and you know how you
predict this i don't even know we've got
a lot of
goods detained that we're presumably
going
to europe um will goods that have not
yet been
bogged down in this situation be
redirected and create a glut
in parts of the world that don't acquire
this canal who knows yeah i don't know
but one of the things about you being on
bci this
uh smithsonian run island in the middle
of lake cartoon in the middle of the
panama canal
is that from one of the sort of terraces
at the field station um
at night after well you had an opposite
schedule for most people because you
were working on bats but
um i i remember sitting sometimes sort
of at dusk
looking out over the canal and seeing
seeing the the boats
and it felt like i'm just making up
numbers here but like
one in four one in five boats said
evergreen
across the side like it's just it's just
a massive shipping company that is on
like
so many of the boats a substantial
fraction minority fraction of the boats
that are out there yeah it's at least
the panama canal
it's a huge line and you know and this
and this boat is actually called ever
given
apparently their names are all
variations on um a theme
yeah so you know um
when somebody writes the iconic song
about this you know like the
the wreck of the edmond fitzgerald it
should be
something like you know the wedging of
the ever lovin ever given evergreen lime
something
it's good yeah um but okay yeah so
that's that's the confusion here is the
ship
is part of the evergreen line yeah the
ship is the ever given
um the title issue changes everything
here because
uh the buoyancy of the ship type
t-i-d-a-l
the tides yeah that's what tides
actually affect their ship so my global
warming joke would not
make any sense at all in the panama
canal right right um
because it's not tidal and global
warming would have to rise above the
locks to
even touch it but in this case the tides
actually do affect it
i will say knowing nothing about what
the right solution is here i do
wonder if we're not going to see them
unload this boat which will be
a bizarre operation that's that's what i
was
thinking early you know a couple days
ago like wow i'm not sure
well it's not easy yeah you know the the
cranes at the dock are made to lift
these containers and it's a very simple
operation from the point of view of
everything is where it needs to be
right you need to float something here
and then put these containers on some
ship that's waiting and the
ship's coming you know aren't supposed
to be you know you
even think about it this way you've got
ships that are designed to go one
direction
right it's not like a train where you
just turn it around
and if you pull them into the canal to
take containers off the thing you can't
turn it around
to go back out yeah so i mean maybe
that's not a big deal maybe they can
pull it out with tugs and it's not you
know it's all doable
um but uh anyway yeah that boat needs to
be lighter
yeah clearly yeah
all right are we are we there with
respect i think we're done with the suez
canal we're done with it now
we're now primarily avoiding a third
disaster
involving evergreen and in this case um
a
uh unresolvable case of the giggles yes
indeed
okay um next up
the former head of the cdc says hey i
actually
think sorry's code v2 came from a lab
yeah
wow wild robert redfield former cdc
director in this video interview with
cnn
um we were going to have zach show a
couple minutes of this for people who
aren't already aware of it yeah
unfortunately we can't hear it while
it's showing so we have to remember
what's in this so zach
um you want to show the first 2.0
through 2.05 and then we'll say
something then we'll jump to the next
little section
due to circumstances beyond our control
all right we're giving it a second yeah
um
yes we're apparently giving it a second
so for those listening this is just
dead dead time so let us say um
while zach is working on getting the
tech to work
former director of the cdc is speaking
out on
when and where he thinks the coronavirus
pandemic originated
here is dr robert redfield when he sat
down with sanjay gupta
[Music]
if i was to guess this virus started
transmitting somewhere in september
october and wuhan september october
that's my own view it's an only opinion
i'm allowed to have opinions now you
know i am of the point of view
that i still think the most likely
ideology
of this pathogen and wuhan was a from a
laboratory
you know escaped other people don't
believe that that's fine science will
eventually figure it out
it's not unusual for respiratory
pathogens that are being worked on in a
laboratory to infect
the laboratory worker
it is also not unusual for that type of
research to be occurring in wuhan
the city is the widely known center for
viral studies in china
including the wuhan institute of
virology which has experimented
extensively with bat coronaviruses
it is a remarkable conversation i feel
like we're having here
because you are the former cdc director
and you were the director at the time
this was all happening
for the first time the former cdc
director is stating publicly
that he believes this pandemic started
months earlier than we knew
and that it originated not at a wet
market but inside a lab
in china these are two significant
things to say dr redfield
that's not implying any intentionality
you know it's my opinion right but i am
a virologist
i have spent my life in virology i do
not believe
this somehow came from a bat to a human
and at that moment in time the virus
that came to the human
became one of the most infectious
viruses that we know in humanity
for human to human transmission normally
when a pathogen goes from a zoono to
human
it takes a while for it to figure out
how to become more and more efficient in
human human transmission
i just don't think this makes biological
sense so in the lab do you think that
that
process of becoming more efficient was
happening is that what you were
suggesting let's just say i have
chronovirus that i'm working on
most of us all right so uh for those who
were just
listening on screen throughout most of
that interview
uh with uh cd's former cdc director
redfield it says
cnn has written former cdc director says
he thinks coveted 19 originated in a
chinese lab but has no
evidence yeah i hear this claim a lot
there's no evidence for this hypothesis
well of course everybody says theory
which they shouldn't um but
there's no evidence which is
preposterous this is tremendous there's
a tremendous amount of evidence
what i would say is there is no evidence
of a natural origin there is evidence it
is not
direct evidence of a laboratory origin
and so that is striking
and the idea i mean i'm troubled by the
journalism that surrounds this in this
case
i think that this cnn report um
effectively doesn't go anywhere new the
only news here is that somebody who was
in a positioned
in a position to know what was being
said on the inside
has come to this conclusion right
and uh you know we'll link to the whole
this whole little
little piece in the show notes but you
then have the
the interviewer being somewhat dismayed
with the cnn people um whereas
um he does not appear dismayed here with
with redfield
and maybe now um before we say anything
more we should jump to
um the next little bit of this sec
starting at 3 40
that we wanted to show where we have
to 418
yep
expressing is that there certainly are
possibilities as i mentioned just a few
moments ago
of how a virus adapt itself to
a efficient spread among humans
you know one of them is in the lab and
one of them which is the more likely
which most public health officials
agree with is that it likely was
below the radar screen spreading
in the community in china for several
weeks if not a month or more which
allowed it when it first
got recognized clinically to be pretty
well
adapted
so
so that was fouchy for those who were
only listening rather than watching
and um it doesn't look like
science it looks like politics
yeah this is clearly politics and but
it's
but it's veiled as science it's veiled
as
this you know the foremost authority
that we are supposed to be listening to
scientifically on this topic
and um being being back on his heels
um doesn't feel good and so it the it's
sort of more clearly
a political response so i i would say
i think it goes one step beyond that
that in in essence what we are now
watching
is many mainstream publications and
broadcasts
that have taken up a very clear position
you know
under the false banner follow the
science
um scientific consensus whatever it is
that's being
deployed right they have got themselves
in a bind because
one would expect that if this indeed
were of natural origin
evidence for that would emerge and
evidence that was inconsistent with the
laboratory erection
would also emerge and they would find
themselves relieved to have
taken up that position instead what
we're seeing is the opposite
and they are now figuring out how to
live in a new world where this
hypothesis that they did not want to
survive
has um become unstoppable by virtue of
how well
it matches um the evidence in questions
so
i think what you're watching is a sort
of jockeying for position
so fox news for example has done some
actually quite credible reporting on
this topic
and cnn has been on the wrong side of it
that's not to say that we know what
happened but it is to say
that um dismissing the idea of a lab
leak has never been reasonable
and any journalistic outfit that has
said there is only one possible
explanation for the origin of this virus
at any point up until now um
is not doing good journalism right
they're doing something else
and so the question is what are they
doing is some is it a business thing
right yeah is it a are they doing the
are they carrying water for somebody
with a
um an interest in where the science goes
and so of course
if you're not really paying attention to
the lab leak
question if you are if you have been
going along
with the new york times and cnn and
these other publications and now
suddenly this shows up on cnn it seems
like
news oh you know this former head of cdc
is taking this hypothesis seriously of
course what he says in that clip
isn't anything that hasn't been
discussed here
you know we discussed it on mar it has
been widely discussed
on twitter it has been discussed in the
wall street journal matt ridley has
covered it so the point is there's
nothing new here
all he's saying is that he's convinced
and that is interesting because
um it means that then nothing was said
behind the scenes that actually
tells us this lab league did not happen
i mean but that is new
right that like this this is new because
this is someone
with both uh the the background
to understand what is potentially going
on
and someone who had access to
potentially more information than any of
the rest of us have
and you know no he is not laying out all
the reasons that he
thinks this in this very brief interview
clip we don't know
we don't know all of what he thinks or
why he thinks it
um the idea that he has no evidence is
not true
what we know is that he has not
presented the evidence here
in this interview in this little tiny
interview that's all well what he says
is the pattern of emergence that this
virus showing up and being
very good at transmitting between people
immediately with no evidence of it
having learned that trick either in
people
or in an intermediate host is is the
evidence and the point is that that
isn't new
i have of course seen lots of people say
well this is a discredited
cdc head on the basis of
having botched the initial reaction to
covid
um which is obviously irrelevant this is
not
uh this is not a an accurate challenge
and then we have on the other side we
have fauci who is
also highly placed arguably more
expert in viruses and
the challenges of pandemics however
what they don't say here as far as i
know is that fauci
is compromised having been in the
uh the chain of influence that resulted
in
the gain of function research taking
place in spite of
very serious objections pre pre-coping
right years ago but the point is okay if
fouchy
called it wrong thought gain of function
research was a great idea and in fact i
think if you look at his
reasoning assuming that his reasoning is
what he said publicly he wanted to have
a very rapid pathway to generating
vaccines so that a pandemic couldn't get
ahead of you
right that's a noble and that's a good
idea
on the other hand if that led him to
advance gain of function research which
resulted in the lab leak which
then you know crashed the world economy
and uh killed millions of people
then that's a major error and covering
his ass is not valid we need to know
what happened
so there's a lot of levels of what's
going on here but at some level what
you're watching is the mainstream
trying to figure out how to pivot to
what those of us
who have been paying attention to the
evidence itself have recognized was
a very viable hypothesis and much more
viable
than the traditional explanation um
you know we've known that for you know
since march of
last year so anyway interesting to watch
the big
players pivot but it's also frustrating
because the big players are in some
sense you know suddenly people are now
going to feel licensed to think
about this as a possibility as if it
just dawned on the scientific community
that it is one
and that's not the case
i'm not i'm not plagued by that i mean
that that will always be how things are
you you know you do
you don't if a hypothesis
is being uh subverted or not taken
seriously for any reason uh
those few people who insist on talking
about it
are not going to be recognized by um
by everyone as talking about the
important thing
um until something else happens ah but
so the fact is that there is a
it's i don't know if you know there is a
paper trail there are several papers
yeah
um and there are also there's also now
like a
pixel trailer there's like a video trail
you know there are many of us
even who haven't written papers on this
who have been talking about this so um
you know the fact that this may be the
thing like i'm grateful i thought
i was hoping that um was it was it
ridley's article
in the was it like the new york post
intelligencer
in december of last year was that ridley
i can't remember
oh no no you're talking about uh why am
i
blanking on his name oh nicholas baker
nicholson yeah
yeah yeah um i was hoping that that
might be the thing that actually broke
this sort of
this loose there have been a number of
these like oh it's getting out you know
there's been a couple of wall street
journal op-eds as you say
and um you know any any one of them that
manages to get
um the the monolithic
media representation if anyone who talks
about this as a
as a right-wing conspiracy theorist i'm
in favor of
well of course but i'm deeply troubled
by the pattern here a
if history is any guide those who talked
about this early
will not be vindicated by the system
right the pretense will be oh they were
cranks
and then it just happened that this the
science
discovered this thing isn't it nifty
that we've discovered it rather than
actually they weren't cranks
and you portrayed them as that falsely
so i i'm troubled i'm also troubled
that the pattern is a narrative pattern
right in other words the truth here
is what people are convinced they need
to discuss
rather than what the evidence says and
the problem is that the evidence as i
keep saying the evidence is not
conclusive and there's no direct
evidence of a lab leak there is lots
of evidence that points to a lab leak
that should have resulted in
absolutely everybody who is capable of
interpreting that evidence
saying regretfully this is a possibility
that needs not you know what they've
effectively said
is sure formally we need to leave that
on the list but it's very very
unlikely rather than it is deeply
troubling how likely that is
and how all of the evidence remains
consistent with that hypothesis so
i would much rather see the spectrum of
what we discuss
moved naturally with the evidence and
that put us in whatever awkward position
it puts us in because we've lost a
tremendous amount of time here
fighting a narrative battle over whether
responsible people think this way
and even in this set of clips what fauci
says is nonsense
yeah and i have no doubt that he's smart
enough to know that what he is saying is
nonsense but his point is
oh the solution to the problem that
redfield is pointing out
right a problem that i think redfield is
just reading into what the rest of us
have been saying
there's something very anomalous about
this highly effective
virus reaching uh wuhan and
already being ready to go right in
humans right and what fauci says is oh
that
that logically is not a terrible problem
because in fact it was probably
circulating much earlier and so the
period of time in which it's bumbling
along is just one you haven't discovered
yet but that is
inconsistent with the evidence that we
have about the phylogeny of this thing
where we appear to have
effectively a point source right so
somehow the discussion is moving too
slowly and this is
progress in one regard but it's
maddening if you've been following the
actual evidence
it is moving too slowly i agree with you
about that i do
i think i disagree with you or at least
i'm going to push back against your
framing of
the problem is that it's narrative um
both because um i believe that we can
win with narrative rather than
continuing to lose with narrative
um like i do think that's possible and
i'm a fan of narrative as you are too
but i think you know i think it is
sort of embedded even more deeply in how
i
how i go about viewing the world but i
also think
um and maybe it's just because of that
bias that i understand about myself
um i think it is innate to what humans
are and how we do things
and um try you know arguing for a
non-narrative approach to uh this sort
of thing
will not work because some people will
always be using narrative
and if their narrative is at all
compelling as somehow apparently this
if you're talking loudly you're
conspiracy theorist narrative has been
compelling
to many many many people then those
people using narrative will beat out
those people who don't and i mean i feel
like this is a very analogous argument
to
having religion is a more adaptive
position than not having
okay but i am not arguing against the
importance of narrative what i'm arguing
is that it is necessary in a scientific
milieu that the narrative
follows from and i don't want to say the
evidence itself because the evidence
itself doesn't speak to a narrative
but the hypothetical deductive method in
light of the evidence
does point to various possible
explanations
and the journalists i mean
i don't even understand how this is
possible we are over producing
phds at an incredible rate because of
things we don't need to talk about but
the university produces phds to get its
work done
cheaply because graduate students are
cheap labor so we produce a huge number
of people who are never going to get a
job in the fields in which they train
that means including in in legit fields
including in scientific fields
right exactly and i mean it's especially
true in scientific fields because the
work is expensive you need people who
actually understand the science to teach
the undergraduates and so
asterisk i would say it's especially
true in fields that don't have any
business existing at all
i would say all of those phds are
overproduced yes but from the point of
view of the university
needing the labor and then conspiring to
get it by pretending that there are more
jobs than there are
inducing people to to work for less than
a living wage
in pursuit of a degree we produce all of
these
experts right those people should
many of them end up in journalism and
frankly the things that get
said in journalistic outlets are just
completely unforgivable in light of how
much
spare expertise there is produced by the
system there's no way that this
narrative needs to be driving this story
because you could have people
who are you know uh
educated enough to get it tracking this
and saying hey boss i hate to tell you
this but the lab leak hypothesis is
absolutely viable
yeah i guess i i hope i feel like there
may be a piece missing in
the story you just told um and you know
maybe it's
maybe the overproduction of phds is
really of people who
really are skillful and creative think
like original thinkers who are able to
also assess a whole bunch of technical
information
what we have seen is that um a
tremendous number and i think it's a
tremendous majority
of phd programs at least that we have
had access to
do not involve people actually even
doing their own research from beginning
to end oh yeah
right so you know if you've got a whole
bunch of people ending up with phds and
sciences who walk into someone else's
lab with someone else's grants
who are already asking who already have
a research program
and you say okay well you're going to do
this part and yeah they maybe figure out
an experimental design and maybe they
figure out how to do the analysis or
whatever but it's
you know it's it's actually somewhat
rare
for for in some departments and i don't
know how widespread that is but i think
it's pretty widespread
for people who end up with phds who
actually have even done a complete piece
of their own research
and that's i mean that's terrible but
that doesn't that does mean if that's
true
that you may have a whole lot of people
with phds who wouldn't actually be able
to go do journalism
because they wouldn't necessarily be
able to see what is true
but but i think what it would do implied
in what you said is that would free them
from the perverse incentives that being
in
a situation where peer review depends on
your peers respecting you and you not
having
overturned the status quo by saying
actually i think that was a lab leak
like you know outside of academia there
are some perverse incentives that are
hidden to most people
and in journalism i'm sure there are two
but they're going to be different ones
i think that's well said and this
actually i don't have it
queued up here but what the president
said uh in response to this
is indicative of exactly the problem
you're pointing to the president
basically
you're talking about fighting you're
talking about now yeah um he said
something words to the effect of
he of course misused the word theory
something like i have my own theories
as to what happened but i'm going to
wait until the scientific community
resolves this which is like
understandable but wrong six different
ways
right a that's not how science works the
scientific community is perfectly
capable of being entirely wrong
right the science itself points to an
answer and the scientific community can
get it wrong and the point you're making
which i
fully agree with is that the perverse
incentives
inside of the system make that all too
likely so
if what biden means by this is let's
wait and see what mainstream virology
thinks about this
mainstream virology has now two big
problems
one it allowed work to go on
that whether or not it did create this
pandemic
could have created this pandemic and
then two it doubled down
and doubled down isn't even right it did
it a hundred times it told us
this is not viable the evidence does not
support
lab leak right and it kept telling us
that and so the point is now in order to
not
have to explain why it told us something
wasn't possible that clearly is
it's just continuing to cover so you
can't say
that science is a process it's awesome
you should follow it yeah i agree with
that much right
and then it's like well how do we know
what the process said oh ask the experts
in it ah they all have the same conflict
of interest god damn it
right wouldn't it be great if a bunch of
people who were trained by this system
then left the conflict of interest zone
and were in a position to comment on it
right that would be really useful and
yet instead what we get
is journalism that if you understand the
basics of what's being described you're
just
constantly like did i read what i you
know this is insane
how low level the errors are yeah well
and i mean you've just described the
like wouldn't it be great if people
who know stuff were able to leave the
zone with the conflict of interest and
you know in some ways
this is what we have done but we are
also not virologists not vaccinologists
not public health experts not
epidemiologists
but the like uber generalist
framing of evolutionary theory which um
you know you can apply to everything
outside of like rocks and quarks
allows a person to walk in if they have
a bit of a bit of background and
are able to look at facts
dispassionately and have the humility
and and demand of themselves that they
come back and say when they're wrong
that they were wrong
you can walk into any number of complex
systems and say okay nope not my
expertise haven't published here
but let's see what this means what's the
evolutionary what can we predict about
what's going to happen evolutionarily
based on what information we do know and
you know that's
that's what we're doing yeah i agree and
i uh i want to be
increasingly clear about this we are not
epidemiologists we are not
even molecular biologists but i don't
think evolution
is uh somehow secondary
in this story at all well as you've
already pointed out it's exactly
the thing that redfield names oh it's
what both of them are talking well
because fauci is responding to redfield
but they're they're exactly talking
about i don't you know basically
redfield saying which
i i believe you said on mar and we've
both said here on darkhorse many times
um a virus that has just
made the jump um from you know from
another species to humans
would take some time to figure out how
to go human to human very fast
and um this is you know that that's in a
nutshell
and there was apparently no time right
and so it's
there are explanations that could fit
fouchy has landed on one
that doesn't right so the point is
interesting now that at least the
english-speaking world is now
juggling something central to the covid
story
and what does it hinge on wouldn't you
know it it hinges on a question of
evolutionary dynamics right
and of course this has been true all
along the fundamental questions here are
not
more molecular than they are
evolutionary they are both molecular
and evolutionary and epidemiological
right that's the nature of these stories
and so the question is what's your road
in
and if the idea is the virologists are
going to pull rank on the evolutionary
biologists well on what basis are you
doing that other than power
right that's not science stay in my lane
the highway is evolutionary right
yeah they're very well said the highway
is entirely evolutionary whether it's
understood to be
or not all right now
are we where you wanted to go on that
topic yeah okay
um because it connects what we have just
discussed connects with one of the
things that was on my list and i don't
know if it's next
on your list i was going to talk about
saffron next
um is there can i slot in the question
of the amazon
i suppose you want to go after after
that for for reasons but um
you can you can go for it okay so i want
to do this because
it's relevant zach could you put up the
rt
um oh boy can you put that on the screen
i can actually see it
all right so here we have a story from i
think it's a couple weeks back actually
um amazon rainforest now most likely
warming earth's atmosphere not cooling
it
scientists warned uh [ __ ] sake
yeah for [ __ ] sake can you scroll down
a little bit too i want to see if the
yeah and then also on rt in the middle
of this article
pollution cools the planet pandemic
induced lockdowns raise global
temperatures in 2020.
now that second thing is actually
not far-fetched right it is true and it
is actually
pretty well known and pretty well
studied that industrial pollutants
do block a certain amount of uv
radiation and reflect it back into space
basically
increasing albedo and so the shutdown of
some fraction of our industrial capacity
is capable of doing that but you start
to put these things
together so scroll back up to the uh the
title
and it's painting a picture here by the
way i'm
a little bit tickled that's a picture of
the amazon and i believe
those yellow trees are going to be
tabibuya flowering which is
a tropical phenomenon and when these
flowers fall to the ground it's a little
bit like
um like uh fall colors and
yeah i'm not i don't remember the range
of taboo yeah and that doesn't look like
the same yellow as taba booyah to me
but uh all right i'm a big fan of that
tree
so yes i'm just not going to sign on to
that being that tree all right well
we'll see okay um but uh actually i do
think taboo
gets that south but anyway the point
here is this article if you actually
read it and i'm not going to bother
going through it but i did start to read
it to figure out what the hell this was
saying because that title doesn't make
any sense no it doesn't
um what the article describes
is not that the amazon is contributing
and you know mind you the title says the
amazon
forest is contributing how is the amazon
forest contributing to global warming
according to this article
by being cut down and burned
right yeah that's that's quite a sleight
of hand
it's quite a sleight of hand it's you
know i i struggle to even figure out
what the president destabilizes country
by dying
exactly or uh you know
franz ferdinand triggers world war
right i mean you know it's it's insane
now here's the problem
you don't have to have a phd you don't
you don't need a bachelor's degree you
just need to have paid attention
in high school science to know that the
amazon forest itself
probably isn't really capable of
contributing one way or the other
to global warming by virtue of
equilibrium
right the amazon rainforest is made out
of
molecules those molecules overwhelmingly
are the result of photosynthesis that
has taken the sun's light
and taken co2 from the atmosphere and it
has linked those co2 molecules together
into sugars and into cellulose which is
basically sugar
molecule reflected right strings of
sugar molecules that's an amazing
process
but the point is a certain amount of the
co2 that might be in the atmosphere
is stuck in trees and other plants and
animals and
everything else in the amazon and no
[ __ ]
if you burn that stuff it releases it
back into the atmosphere
right very quickly if you just cut it
down and leave it sitting it'll do so
more slowly but nonetheless
this was like this is the observation of
the first ecologist
right it's this is really basic it's
it's the most
basic uh understanding of what this
thing is now the amazon
could over time pick up some biomass you
know if you leave the amazon b there are
processes that could result in it
getting heavier
we're going to take a little bit of co2
out of the atmosphere but ultimately
it's got to stabilize somewhere
right and at that point if you cut it
down or burn it yep you're going to
return a bunch of that stuff to the
atmosphere
if it's expanding in scope it will be
taking up more
and if it is being burned down or or
otherwise receding as
um as the forests that uh you know
apparently
once were in northern africa where we
now have vast desertification
then the opposite will happen right and
there are other factors that are not
involved in this equilibrium so can you
put the
article back up zach
so if you look at the amazon rainforest
from above you will notice
that it is quite dark
so that has an albedo impact that the
fact of the amazon rainforest
will capture a certain amount of heat
because it's dark and so it will absorb
sun's energy whereas if it was light it
would reflect it like the poles do
so that's not an equilibrium question
but that's not what the article is about
just just to be clear though with regard
to albedo
cut down an acre of tropical rainforest
and what tends to be exposed is
darker um you tend the albedo effect
actually goes in the opposite direction
at least
upon uh first pass with regard to the
cutting that the the bare soil um tends
to be dark and i have i
did not pull it up i have an albedo
chart here somewhere from an object i
think this is not always the case but in
any case
my only point is it's not that every
effect on
uh global climate of the forest is
subject to this equilibrium but the
topic of this article
is about carbon and it is about
the title and the article effectively
the underlying science appears viable
here i can't say it's
right or wrong but i can say there's
nothing in the science that's being
reported
that isn't correct but from the point of
view of the journalism
is absolutely insane and anybody with a
basic
understanding of equilibrium dynamics
and even just
the most superficial uh understanding of
what photosynthesis is and what it
produces
would know that it's not right and yet
here it is being broadcast
and i saw not a single complaint about
it right so
you know to the point about
um for some reason though we are
producing a great many people
who at least ostensibly should be
leaving the academy
with a great deal of expertise our
journalism does not reflect an
excess of expertise it reflects all of
these insane conclusions being spread
around as if they make scientific sense
and the rest of us uh behaving as if
that's normal yeah
an unfortunately true understatement our
journalism does not reflect and excess
of expertise
no it does not neither neither though
does academia at the moment right well
or
expertise doesn't mean what we would
like it to mean it means
something else some kind of technical
competence that does not involve
apparently the ability to extrapolate
right right
right exactly okay um can we talk about
saffron yeah let's do that let's talk
about saffron
um why are we talking about saffron i'm
not gonna tell you why we're talking
about saffron at first i'm going to read
you a little bit first just a paragraph
um from this amazing book
on food and cooking by harold mcgee
second edition 2004
really if you're at all interested in
what your ingredients are and how
how cooking works and um and
um various traditions throughout um
throughout the world this is
this is fair to say i've produced the
book a little bit a narrative approach
to cooking both at the level of
why things transition when you do
certain stuff to them
and where the ingredients to some degree
i mean i guess it really appeals to both
my scientific and my narrative
side so he's got for instance here this
is a survey he's got a survey of
temperate spices followed by a survey of
tropical spices
and he spends a page and a half on
saffron i must say some of the
intemperate spices are my favorites yeah
you know they're the best but a little
bit angry
uh they're a little a little hot yeah
yeah uh yes it's a whole
whole page whole thing on chili's and
capsaicin
so you know he goes chemistry he goes
molecular biology he goes culinary
history he goes narrative he goes
cultural anthropology it's it's great so
again uh
on food and cooking by harold mcgee just
the first paragraph on saffron before we
go into why we're talking about saffron
saffron is the world's most expensive
spice
a testament not only to the labor
required to produce it but to its unique
ability to impart both an unusual flavor
and an intense yellow color to foods
it is a part of the flower of a kind of
crocus crocus sativas
which is probably domesticated in or
near greece during the bronze age
the saffron crocus was carried eastward
to cashmere before 500 bce
in medieval times the arabs took it
westward to spain and the crusaders to
france and england
the name comes from the arabic for
thread today iran and spain are the
major producers and exporters
they use saffron in their respective
rice dishes pilaf and paella
the french and their fish stew and
bouillabaisse the french and their
french stew comma which is called
boya base and the italians in risotto
milanese the
indians in biryanis and milk sweets so
there's a whole
lot more about the biology and and such
of saffron but
that's it in in a nutshell
uh he says it's probably greek some
people think it's iranian in origin it's
not totally clear
it's several thousand years old we've
been and apparently domesticated for
several thousand years which is
remarkable um so it's either
a human creation entirely or um
the result of you know through
artificial selection uh where we were
actively putting stuff together
or a discovery um for reasons that i'll
talk about in a little bit
of what was surely a mutation that
wouldn't have persisted
that we then acted to help propagate and
have
have moved forward by several thousand
years um so we've been using it for
pigment
it's in some parietal arts and some wall
art um
in um from from older humans
medicine uh for various uh ailments
which is what we're gonna talk about
here
and of course spice um although the
description of it um you know i
i admit that i think i've never had um
fresh enough saffron to be so it's so
expensive that
very quickly i've never really been able
to determine um a flavor but
uh it's said to have a hay-like aroma
and taste which when said that way one
wonders why it's
you know so remarkably coveted in
in at least particular parts of the
world um
so there's this paper
um oh that's unfortunate uh let's see
hold on
i can pull it up this way hopefully this
paper
zachary in a minute here you can show
um that just came out in the journal
physiology and behavior
called impact of saffron croco sativas
lin supplementation and resistance
training on markers implicated in
depression and happiness levels in
untrained young males so i was just
pleased enough with that title to end up
reading this paper it's written by it's
it's a bunch of people
um a bunch of researchers out of iran um
and
one person uh in uh some france and u.s
but this is um
the the untrained young males being
talked about here are iranian
young iranian men um who were
and you know they started with 36 and it
went down to i think 28 so they had 14
men in one category and 14 men and
another these are all men
who um you know weren't smoking or
drinking
or engaged in any resistance training
any um resistance training
um in advance of this and to half the
young men
they um gave them a uh a series of
resistance trainings for i think it was
six weeks
and um after the resistance training
every day they gave them a saffron
supplement and at the same time every
day when they weren't engaged in the
resistance training they gave them
a saffron supplement and the other half
the men
same exact resistance training and they
gave a placebo
at the same moment so the only thing
that was different was the saffron
but they were effectively trying to
control for the well-known phenomenon
that resistance training
also deals with depression right that
resistance training itself
um is effectively an antidepressant and
so what you know is there going to be a
discernible difference for men who
aren't alway
already engaged in resistance training
um if you start them on it
will they get will they get better turns
out yes will they get more better
if you give if you have them engage in
business training and take
relatively small amounts of saffron the
answer is yes
um fascinatingly and so they looked at a
number of
metrics here you can take my screen
offset because this is just uh
uh but let me just see but the the
things that they looked at that
increased were
um anandamide oh i can't even pronounce
this next one i don't know what it is
t uh two arachidonal
glycerol also known as 2ag
serotonin excuse me serotonin
dopamine uh and beta endorphin
all increased as did in just
questionnaires
reported levels of happiness in the
resistance training plus saffron group
more than they did in the resistance
training without saffron group
um i think i have that right there's a
little bit there's there are a lot of
things they were looking at so i may
have put one of those things there
wrong column but all those things
definitely increased in both groups
uh or um that the first did in the first
group
it seemed like you had something to say
well right i have
recently come to the conclusion that if
you're happy and you know it you're not
paying attention but some of those
people may just be on saffron
yeah yeah i don't like this formulation
you don't like just formulating if
you're happy you know you're not paying
attention
well i mean 2021 yeah but it's a
temporary condition
for sure i hope so okay so
um one of the things that saffron seems
to do actually and this is not from this
paper this apparently
i did not know so i just went down the
saffron rabbit hole today
there's a wealth of literature most of
which is not
immediately available you have to ask
for it through interlibrary loan and
such
so i'm not going to show you any of the
other papers but um on
all of the actual known antidepressant
effects of saffron and it appears to
have a very similar actual mechanism
to fluoxetine which is prozac if memory
serves
which is that it inhibits the reuptake
of serotonin into synapses
okay so this may be where you're headed
but the interesting thing here we have a
synthetic molecule
that blocks the reuptake of serotonin
for which you could make all of the
usual
observations about the hazard of not
knowing
what the consequence of this will be and
then you have
thousands of years of use of a natural
molecule that does this
in which we are safe to make the
assumption that at least
in the ancestral circumstance this was
not
um bad for the individuals and that
there's reason to think that in fact
it was positive by virtue of the fact
that it is not free to cultivate saffron
in fact it's labor intensive
and yet it persisted and spread from one
culture to the next
so it provides no caloric benefit and
it's self-limiting in terms of the ms so
it is it is toxic in large amounts but
it's really hard to get enough saffron
in any but a modern
incredibly wealthy environment to to
hurt yourself with it
colors things yellow so it has a caloric
value but not
caloric absolutely i mean i think that's
worth noting
in past i approve of that challenge all
right that joke
okay feel free to borrow that joke that
one
has been approved yeah yeah um
all right so so yeah the part part of
part of
the places to think about here are
exactly what you just said that
um finding a similar mechanism
in a molecule that is in a plant that
has had
been in um basically co-evolutionary
relationship
with humans for thousands of years
is knowing nothing else very much likely
to be a lot safer
than creating synthesizing in a lab a
molecule that has the same mechanism of
action
but is also you know the additional
reason why that might not be as safe
just aside from not knowing what the
titration level should you know how much
you should be taking in all of this
um is you know what else is in the
saffron it's it's a it's a
complex it's you know it's pollen from a
plant
it's pollen i think yeah um
what do you call them the pistols or
stamens i don't even remember
we're not botanists i wasn't gonna i
wasn't gonna hide behind that but i
probably should
yeah um yeah i'm trying to remember what
the things on the top of the corn are
but anyway
um the threads
okay i think they're answers but anyway
go ahead
i don't remember where i was going um
you were talking about the
uh advantage of a natural molecule as
compared to the synthetic
molecule so there's so much else also
that you're getting when you're eating
saffron
right it's not just the lab synthesized
molecule
which is what you were saying as well
but one of the pieces of the story that
is
not that i haven't mentioned yet and
there are many but
the one that i do want to mention before
we move on is that
um the crocus species that saffon is
saffron is from
is triploid and it cannot reproduce
sexually
as a result and it is entirely asexually
reproducing
and um basically humans produce it
by separating anyone who's ever planted
bulbs knows um you know sometimes it's
bulbs sometimes it's quaran's there's
just
there's a botanical distinction between
the two but they seem
similar to the in this case it's going
to matter okay
this is more like uh garlic than it is
like an onion
and because it's like garlic you can
take a what's called a tooth
one clove of garlic and you can yeah i
i need a garlic plant i believe that's
right for for this species of crocus i'm
not 100 sure it's why i paused
well i think i think it's implied in the
fact that it's a corn it's a chorum out
of bulb
yeah um so it's it's dependent
on us which means um you know it's not
it's not really changing it's it's
benefiting from its association with us
in which we take its
uh take its pollen and eat it and paint
walls with it and use it medicinally
but it is it is never reproducing
sexually and so there's a question of
course
again of you know where did it originate
was it a mutation that would have been a
complete dead end but for the lucky
discovery
by you know presumably a single human
several thousand years ago that that was
actually
you know that when they when they rubbed
up against it and then wiped their hands
on
their mouth they felt better afterwards
i mean that seems like an unlikely
series of events
especially for them to then be like
maybe it was the orange stuff on my lips
right um although it being so highly
colored may have made it easier to trace
yes it also uh suggests a yeah easier to
trace but it also suggests a reason
that it might have been introduced into
cuisine
right and so just as a colorant right
and then
it has this other effect yeah absolutely
so
um in trying to figure out some of what
was going on
with this with this
species that is entirely dependent on
humans i ended up at
this really confused website and so this
is my segue to the last thing we're
going to talk about
wait before you segue though one other
point about this
which is there are really two things at
least two things
that make saffron even if saffron is
doing effectively the same thing
as ssris that are synthetically made are
doing
there are two reasons um that the
natural version is probably
uh much better one
is the one we've already pointed to that
uh
it comes in a context that is that has
stood the test of time
but the other thing is it may come in a
tradition that titrates it properly in
other words
yes you are hacking
a physiological system there are reasons
that you might want to hack a
physiological system rather than go with
your endogenous programming for example
this won't be the case
probably in iran or greece but
if you change latitudes for example and
your serotonin system
was not calibrated to your new situation
you might be able to use saffron to
modulate it for let's say winter or
something like that
but were that the case you would imagine
that
it would you know the world has not
evolved with supermarket-like foods
where you can source a strawberry you
know in
in february right the world functions
where
foods become available at different
times and so traditions have built into
them
a kind of uh you know a calendar of
foods as it were
and you might imagine prediction of the
hypothesis that actually this does
travel with humans because of its ssri
uh like effect you might imagine that
foods that accompany the part of
the year that you want to recalibrate
would be high in saffron
and that other parts of the year might
be low in it or something like that well
interesting too um actually that
um you know seasonal depression is
something that afflicts
many people and um that would likely
have been the case
even pre-industrial lights and such and
this crocus unlike most although like
some others
is autumn blooming whoa so this you know
this is the saffron is becoming
available and you know it doesn't save
particularly well unless you've got
um deep freeze basically you know it
freezes okay
um and it's you can you basically heat
dry it
and then it preserves a little bit but
it's going to it's it's going to be the
most abundant and the freshest
exactly as the days are getting darker
so this is perfect
it blooms at an odd time and it cannot
be preserved
therefore the prediction of the
hypothesis
is that it is properly uh targeted
to a a place where physiology is
desirably hacked and that you can't
screw up
because it's very hard to have it at the
wrong moment
that would be fascinating of course that
would require you to know
which populations have an ancestral it
sounds like iran
and greece would be two but you know in
order to figure out where
the plant picked up that trick yeah
assuming that that trick is calibrated
to a population which population was it
exactly and interesting iran and greece
aren't exactly adjacent you know
interesting that those are the two
possible
source populations yeah but also that
sort of fits in this story too
um because the nature so
to catch people up because it's
non-sexual it doesn't produce a viable
seed
right which is uh
fine in this case because it produces a
corn the corn can be broken apart and
therefore one plant can produce many
plants by planting the corms and
supplementing them and so you get many
plants but it also makes it highly
transportable
right um that's true so it may you know
you can take the items and by keeping
them in
root cellar like conditions they are
dormant and you can
travel over long distances and so maybe
not so surprising that non-adjacent
populations both have a very
ancient relationship with it because it
only takes one person to carry it over a
mountain range
for it to show up somewhere yeah that's
good i like that
okay so while i was trying to figure out
some some of that i came across
um this website
um which i'm trying to make bigger here
um which
you should pay no attention to at all
because it's truly confused and
confusing
and i'll just read the bottom half of
the second
paragraph here the crocus sativis is an
asexual plant meaning that this plant
does not reproduce asexually
in order to reproduce itself the croco
sativas must undergo reproduction with
the help of tubers
so you know i read that and went there's
nothing on the site that could possibly
be of value because it's that confused
and of course i did go looking a little
bit more and the site
is deeply confused across a lot of
things but um this
zach if i may thank you um the fact that
that is out there
on an official looking site about all
the information you ever need to know
about saffron
struck me as um
another piece of the puzzle as to why we
are such a confused people now
and you know this to this point
specifically
this site can't even tell the difference
between asexual and sexual reproduction
when it's trying to make a point about
exactly that thing
right right central issue it is the
central issue and it's confused it twice
in two sentences
and it seemed to me so this
in thinking about confusion about
sex and gender and sexuality um
we are not going to spend a ton of time
talking about
um detransitioning right now so
um but but there is a there is a new
thing
that is happening that is worth saying
some some things about
um i don't like to rely on twitter as a
source
um but there's a story that's breaking
that seems to be almost entirely on
twitter there are a few
just medium articles but to the degree
that they're talking about they're
citing the twitter stuff so we're gonna
we're gonna go to twitter here
basically 60 minutes we are told
the long-running um cbs i think
newshour show has been planning a
segment on d
transitioners that is people who have
transitioned um
to the other sex or gender depending on
who you're talking to
um and who have decided after some time
that it was a mistake and that they're
going to detransition back into their
natal sex the sex that they were
born as um and as a result
of um a lot of activist hubbub about
this it seems that uh
cbs may be actually rethinking
rethinking whether or not to do this and
that that i find
yet another piece of dangerous evidence
that our journalism is being run by
narrative and by politics rather than
by um you know by actually trying to
discover what's true
so let's just um show a couple of the
the tweets in question before talking
about this we have
um jennifer i will show this in just a
second zach
jennifer finney boylan who's a trans
woman and also a barnard professor and a
contributing opinion writer for the new
york times
who had 28 pieces in new york times in
2020 alone
so this is not an infrequent contributor
first introduced this to the world um
here
okay zachary um
tweet from march 20th there's going to
be a 60 minutes on d transitioners
she writes they asked me to be a talking
head and i said i prefer not to be part
of this story they said please
i said you ought to talk to tori peters
or at least someone
afab since that's the focus they said
we'd really like you
jennifer phil uh finney boylan i said
i'm honored but i think this is a
terrible idea for a story where i focus
on this small group of outliers
when you could focus on the struggles
and triumphs of so many other trans
folks
so just stepping out of this for a
moment trans is itself an outlier group
and trans has gotten a ton of press
in the last five and ten five or ten
years like
really more than any group of that size
warrants by the numbers and so for
people in
a tiny group of outliers who have been
getting much more press and their
numbers represent
to be complaining about people within
their group
who frankly may or may not be outliers
getting any press at all
seems like the best spin i can put on it
is it's the height of irony
it's the height of irony and it's also
uh
obviously duplicitous yes
so that would be a slightly less
generous interpretation it's a yes
slightly less generous but the simple
fact is the reason that d
transitioners are forbidden and that
there would be pressure put on 60
minutes is that
the strongest argument for a go
slow approach let us leave children to
develop
as they will um and not leap to
conclusions
is that not only do does dysphoria
so regularly clear up on its own
but that many people who do transition
decide later it didn't solve the issue
that they were hoping it would solve and
decide to transition back at which point
you can't fully transition back right
there are
downstream consequences of this and so
um
you know obscuring the awkward fact of
many people who have thought that they
wanted to transition and discover
later that they got bad advice or had
misunderstood things
is really it's going to put people in
harm's way this story needs to be
covered because everybody who's thinking
of transitioning needs to consider the
possibility
that it isn't the solution for them yes
exactly as for instance abigail
schreier's excellent book needs to be
out there and available to people and
not
be you know taken off of the virtual
shelves at amazon
um just two more blue check marks on
twitter
who are tweeting about this and who who
have cultural sway
we have chase strangio at the you know
famous at least in some circles um trans
lawyer at aclu
who quote tweets the boil and tweet
thread that i just read the beginning of
saying this story is deliberately airing
at a time of dangerous assaults on trans
healthcare and trans lives
while we as trans people are harassed
and gaslight when we try to advocate for
our ability to just live
to just live i feel like i know who's
being gaslit
and it's not chase strangio right well
that's the core of gaslighting now isn't
it yes it is uh so
you know at a time of dangerous assaults
on trans healthcare and trans lives
that will always be the claim that will
always be the claim
and any group no matter how you define
that group will always be experiencing
something they should not be
experiencing because that is the nature
of existence
so there is nothing in here that is
falsifiable
and yet the entire thing is of a tone
that seems exactly wrong and actually
quite deceitful so just one more of
these
uh here we have someone um actually
sorry zach give me my
screen back just for a minute um so i
can see this is someone
who is the former editor-in-chief of out
magazine
and the former chief commercial officer
of teen vogue
uh teen vogue which seems to be one of
the sort of spear points
of a lot of this madness so
um the twitter account is pf bacardi
again quote tweets the original boylan
tweet thread saying the media
literacy around trans folks is nothing
short of dangerous
i hope the folks at 60 minutes know
there's a human toll to their
irresponsibility
each and every person affiliated with
selecting this narrative for air time
should be held accountable held
accountable
the idea that there are stories of real
people who have experienced
real pain and real harm and their
stories should not be
told is a remarkable claim
yes and the remarkable in the slightest
veiled threat holding accountable people
for telling stories
like for example jesse single who
has indeed been uh falsely portrayed
and you know what would the term be
demonized online
who has been uh quite good about
reporting
on all sides of the trans issue
so i did want to add one other thing
here which
in the spirit of what we were talking
about last week
uh regarding candy and the idea that
there are certain things that are
that fit on a card yeah that actually
tell the story right it strikes me that
at the heart of the issue of transition
and detransition
is the hypocrisy of a movement
and mind you i'm not talking about trans
people you and i draw a distinction
trans
activists are the ones who have become
so
troubling and frightening but
if trans rights are human rights right
if the right to transition is a human
right
then surely people who have already
transitioned
also have the right to transition and
have the right to have
that story told right so my point is if
the only people on earth
who don't have the right to transition
are people who've already done it
something is off
right and if those who are advocating
for trans people are the ones
who are ruling out the discussion then
they are telling you what they're up to
right this is a one-way phenomenon from
their perspective
yes right yes and uh we need to
recognize that and
um we need to frankly stare down the
threats because
you know there is the the group of
people who have decided
that transition is what they need to do
and there is an infinitely large group
of people who have yet to make such a
decision
and many of them are children they are
easily influenced and
they have a right to have normal
development unfold before
irreversible decisions are made on their
behalf exactly
and you know it's not it's not that
everything in this landscape is
clear-cut
right for those extremely rare people
extremely rare people who really would
describe themselves
to you and some of them have described
themselves to us
as having been born in the wrong body
the earlier they would be allowed to
transition the more likely
their their their understood and deeply
felt
brain sex would be could be come to
become in accord with
the body that they are then allowed to
transition into
that is a tiny fraction of of
one percent of humanity a tiny tiny
fraction of probably a hundredth
of one percent for
the vast majority of people
regardless of how they view themselves
how comfortable they are
in their skin whether or not they're gay
straight by
whatever the vast majority of people who
do not end up feeling that the way that
they must live in the world
forever after is as the sex that they
were not born to
messing with development is permanent
and tragic and
going to result in the things like
infertility mental health problems
and other physical problems like bone
density loss yeah and sexual dysfunction
and sexual dysfunction yes all and and
that's and that's an incomplete list
yeah so you it is it is not it is not
the right
of a tiny tiny tiny number of people
to change development for everyone else
and in fact
it's and and and having children have
this thrust on them
because they say something in the spirit
of childhood where they're exploring
identity because that's what childhood
is is should be criminal
it should be criminal it should be um i
would also
um point out that somehow
we have been lured into a conversation
in
which everything downstream of the
concept of trans
is taken to be sacred and this
doesn't make any sense we have said
repeatedly that
too many cultures have trans as some
role ancient cultures for us to imagine
that this is some
new invention or that that it is
inherently a disorder
however this is not the same thing as
saying
pharmaceutical transition and surgical
transition
is ancient it isn't and so to the extent
that we are talking about
who has surgery available to them how
early in life
when can we disrupt a developmental
process
in order to you know to ostensibly
help you these are not simple matters
right and they are very different from
the right to live as you would
right yes right the ability to be
surgically altered as you would
is not a human right right we have not
declared it such
right there are surgeries you can't go
get right so
this is not one of those things and um
we need to stop pretending that it is
compassion for people is
important and the recognition that trans
is something
real and ancient is important that is
very different from
pharmaceutical and surgical alteration
beautiful exactly right all right
well i we will no doubt come back to
this topic and it's various
instantiations but
um uh for now why don't we why don't we
show the thumbnail that we've chosen for
this week
sure and um and just say that these
this is uh in advance of a bike ride
that zachary our 16 year old son
and producer took yesterday out west of
portland on the banks frenonia
trail it was a beautiful day it's an
even more beautiful day here today
in the pacific northwest and
at least in the northern hemisphere
although frankly near the equinox
it should be beautiful pretty much
everywhere at the moment
um do remember to to get outside
and you know make vitamin d while the
sun shines
and get moving get your heart rate up
and you know
be be with the people you love and uh
and just enjoy what the earth is giving
us as opposed to
what the media and the laboratories are
giving us
yeah go out and smile at someone right
have a normal
human interaction outside it's harder
with the mask isn't it
well as you pointed out last time this
rubric where you need two of three of
the protections means you can be
outside and in smiling range without
breathing down someone's neck and not
wearing a mask
absolutely and that would be wise
actually i will say so zach and i just
did you know 20 miles yesterday
and um i don't think zach correct me if
i'm wrong i don't think we saw anyone on
the trail with a mask uh i saw a couple
but
a couple right at the right near the
trailhead maybe i mean throughout but
not too many overall
okay um so maybe a few i don't think
anyone on bikes maybe
only the walkers were wearing masks and
then
we went um we came back through
northwest portland
um to pick up some food and we had to
park a ways away and i left zach with
the car cause the bikes were on the back
of it and i just walked through
slabtown which is just a part of
northwest portland
and like i said it was a beautiful day
it was a friday evening the sun was out
there was you know we've there the the
local government has allowed for a lot
more outdoor seating spilling into
streets actually than would be normal in
times of a non-pandemic so when the
weather is good there's actually
the possibility for people to be ah to
be seeing each other and to actually be
being human with one another
um and i saw almost no one with a mask
out there either on my you know what
amounted to like an eight
block round trip walked just to pick up
the food that we had ordered and it felt
so terrific felt so human and
wonderful and like you know like the
portland that we love
yep yeah absolutely well i'm glad to see
it returning and uh
i'm ready for the warmer weather yeah
indeed
so um with that
we are for those of you with us on
youtube can take a 15-minute break then
be back with a live
q a answering questions from your super
chat
and if you have any questions about how
to do that or anything else you can send
email to darkhorse.moderator gmail.com
again consider joining us tomorrow at 11
a.m on my patreon for a private two-hour
q a
where where it is intimate enough that
we can actually engage with the chat as
it happens
uh you will have before our next live
stream a
um your first of the month patreon
conversation as well
so at higher tier levels brett has two
monthly conversations as well
at his patreon um
yeah we've got a clips channel where
there's lots of good clips
that our wonderful clip sky is
generating and maybe that's it
once again yeah be good to one another
and eat good food and get outside
we will see you next time we're in 15
minutes depending be well
[Music]
you